ante miles de Seguidores eufóricos
celebró su Victoria en el Palacio
presidencial se queda para un tercer
mandato
[Música]
nuestra nación nos ha confiado de nuevo
esta misión por un periodo de cinco años
debemos centrarnos en nuestros sueños
como nación en nuestras ambiciones y
unirnos
fue también desde ankara que su
contrincante quema alquililla tomó la
palabra para admitir su derrota
el pueblo expresó su voluntad de
rechazar una forma de autocracia pero no
fue suficiente lo que me entristece son
las grandes dificultades que tiene
Turquía por delante
estas elecciones ponen finas semanas de
campaña muy polarizada una parte del
electorado soñaba con el cambio una
población hastiada de la crisis
económica del hundimiento de la lira
turca y la concentración del poder en la
presidencia pero para hacer frente a los
desafíos la mayoría ha elegido otro
camino el de la estabilidad no es solo
el líder de Turquía sino que recepta
Jeep erdoan es un líder mundial nuestro
único líder nuestro único guía surgieron
concentraciones espontáneas en varias
ciudades turcas incluso aquí en
gaciantepec en esta ciudad azotada por
el Terrible terremoto del pasado febrero
la confianza entre aduana no ha
flaqueado
[Música]